close your
eyes and you will find
yourself when I was a
boy my mother used to tell me a
story of a demon king and his
army they brought fire and Terror to the
land
until they face the protector of the
people the white
monkey there you
are you are a
beast in this city the rich don't see us
as
people give me the job no one wants to
do I'll do
it anyone who forgets their place it
doesn't turn out well for
[Music]
them this is not the place to work if
you can't handle that sort of
[Music]
stuff every
day I've prayed for a way to protect the
weak I've got an answer to every prayer
I call her
Nikki Minaj big bumper nice life let's
boo
[Music]
it
MC one young two one 2
[Music]
you need to fight for your mother for
all of
us anger will not call to the soul my
[Applause]
son don't call me
[Music]
son it's time to
remember who you are but only love when
will they
learn just one small
Ember can burn down
everything
Mar ladies and
gentlemen are you ready for a fight 1 2
[Music]
here